hello everyone and welcome to a very
weird game from round date of this
year's Tata still Masters Edition it is
uh Fabiano Corona with the white pieces
against Magnus Carlsen and fabi's been
having a great tournament so far he
defeated Lucas and uh alport I believe
uh drew his other game so he's still
without a loss and Magnus uh he did have
that one uh or rather uh two bad games
where he lost two classical games in a
row so he is not having the greatest
Tournament of his life and which makes
uh what happens in this game all the
more interesting because the game is
pretty much wrapped up in six moves
after we leave Theory so uh let's check
it out Fabi has the white pieces he
opens with Ponte E4 we have Ponte E5
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and the bishop to
B5 uh Fabi goes for the rui Lopez a sex
morph is defense by Magnus Bishop to A4
and now Knight to F6 we have castles
Bishop to E7 and now Rook to E1 so very
standard stuff here nothing new but upon
5 Bishop to B3 and the Magnus castles we
have A4 and now Magnus advances his Pawn
all the way to B4 we have Pawn to A5 and
now Pawn to D6 again nothing new here uh
all been played before the the
anti-martial variation we have Fanta C3
and now Rook the B8 we have h3h6 and now
uh Fabi strikes in the center with Pawn
to D4 so very very standard setup uh B
captures and c3b captures and now e
captures on D4 and now uh if white
captures with the c Pawn then black very
happily advances the pawn to D5 so
that's why Fabi plays Knight captures on
D for now you can't play D5 as the
Knight and C6 is hanging and Bishop to
D7 by Magnus and there is one game in
the database for Knight the D2 was
played I was uh played last year and uh
the the game ended in a drone at a very
eventful game between aguin and
voitashek uh so here we have Bishop to f
4x5 be and it is not as of move 15 that
we have a completely new game Magnus
goes Knight to E5 he keeps the knights
in the game also he doesn't want to just
fix white spawn structure we have
Knights the A3 by Fabi and now Rook to
E8 it's all very standard uh moving the
bishop to f8 so The Rook gains control
over the E file thus show back to G3
preparing F4 to kick away this Knight
and Bishop to f8 with Pawn to F4 by Fabi
and now Knight the C6 and now Pawn to E5
uh winning some some very important
squares here we have e captures uh D
captures and E5 F captures and E5 and
now Knight captures on D4 so here
already uh it's uh getting very
interesting what what do you play here
of course you do not touch the Knight on
F6 you first have to recapture on D4 and
now Bishop to C6 by Magnus and this is a
very very tricky move now it seems like
he blundered the Knight on F6 but um
chances are that that is not the case
because if we captures on F6 then yes it
seems like white has everything defended
but now Rook captures anyone with check
and now either you move away the queen
from the defense of the bishop on B3 or
you play Bishop captures than E1 but now
Rook capture some B3 Queen captures and
queen captures on D4 check uh nicely
connecting with the Rook on A1 and now I
have to remove the king look at this
queen cap there's an A1 and now again
everything is being threatened here the
bishop and E1 is singing also the Knight
here
uh is uh hanging so you have to play
Knights the C2 to defend everything and
now just Queen captures on F6 and now if
you count everything uh there's not much
to hope for here with white black is
just up two pawns uh completely winning
also the mighty Bishop fairies here uh
this would not last very long so here
Fabi instead of um uh going for
e-capters and F6 uh wind Bishop to C2
there are other uh moves that you can
play and not lose the game you can play
Queen to seed you can play Rook to F1
you can play Queen to D3 but Bishop to
C2 is one move that loses the game on
the spot uh so feel free to pause the
video and try to figure out why this is
so uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on taking down a
World Chess Championship Challenger if
we remember 2018 and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen to D5 this threatens mating one uh
the problem is even though it it's such
a tiny threat uh there's no way to
defend against it and it's a very
important to not play Rook the B4 first
you you want to play Rook to B for next
and the now a threatening Checkmate
first we'll make it Unstoppable if you
play Rook to B4 first then Bishop to F2
can just um uh defend the pawn uh let me
just show it to you if Rook to B4 then
you're just gonna play Bishop to D2 and
now if Queen uh D5 now you can play
Queen to F3 and white defense black is
better but white to defends however if
you start with Queen the D5 threatening
Checkmate and now there's a problem now
you will no longer be able to play
Bishop to F2 because here Fabi player
Rook to E2 stopped Checkmate but now
Rook the B4 this is what Fabi missed now
Bishop to F2 is impossible uh because uh
just Queen captures on G2 uh defending
with the Queen instead of interposing
with the Rook still uh impossible
because just Queen captures on D4 the
queen is the only defender of the D4
Pawn so here Bobby played King H2 he has
the part with the D4 Pawn but now his
position just falls apart Rook captures
on D4 we have Queen to B1 uh but now
again many many uh cool ways to continue
the game uh any movie is winning here
for black because the position is
winning for black but just for fun uh
feel free to find an instant results for
Fabi uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so again for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on finding the
quickest way to Victory and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook the D2 very very nasty threat
here just going after the rook and The
Rook cannot move away from the defense
of the G2 Pawn so you will trade here
captures captures now again you are
threatening Checkmate here and after
Queen to F1 defending now you're gonna
play Knight H5 you def you you attack
the bishop on G3 uh you save your knight
from F6 but also you are threatening
Bishop captures and A3 and that will
remove the defender of the bishop and C2
and there are just too many threats for
white to handle if you move the bishop
sort of to save your piece uh now look
at this just Knight captures and G3 and
after King captures Queen to G5 check
now you eliminate the E5 pawn and just
uh finish the game look at this King to
H2 now Queen captures an E5 with check
and it doesn't matter what the white
king plays the king to G1 just Bishop
the C5 check you bring the the king back
in into the corner and the bishop to D6
now will end the game if you want to
stop this you can play some like Queen
captures and F7 but after King th8
there's not much to do you have to start
running away with your king now Queen HD
checking F1 and of course this will now
be Checkmate so just uh you know the the
standard power of the bishop pair from
hell so after Queen to B1 Magnus did not
go for this uh he didn't calculate all
that much he played it rather quickly he
wasn't uh he already messed up quite a
lot in this tournament he doesn't want
to mess up more by over calculating so
he just goes for a completely winning
end game he plays Knights the E4 uh
attacks the bishop here and now you
really have to capture an E4 otherwise
you just um uh resign here there's no
good way to deal with this uh so Fabi
tried Bishop captures on e4 but now
Magnus just trades everything Rook
captures Queen captures Queen captures
Bishop captures and now Knight the C4 uh
trying to add a Defender to these spawns
here but now out Rook the B8 we have
rooked to C1 by Fabi and now Rook to B5
uh we have found the E6 trading the epon
for the C Pawn Magnus captures with f
captures an E6 Bishop captures and now
Rook to C5 attacks the bishop Bishop
back to F4 and now Bishop to D5
attacking the
Knight here and he was in this position
unmove 33 that Fabiano caruana resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here the Knight is singing you
can't really move it or rather you have
to move it but after you move it it's
just an even more winning end game for
magnets Rook captures and C1 Bishop
captures and now you just collect the A5
Point you're gonna be up two points this
is uh completely winning doesn't really
matter what white plays the pawn will
fall uh and uh that's uh just Europe to
pawns uh of course you cannot play an
end game if you are down two pawns
against uh uh you know an equally strong
opponent then especially not against
Magnus Carlsen so that's why on this uh
in this position on move 36 Fabiano
Cortana resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so really
remarkable uh bounce back by Magnus
Carlsen in this Tata steel 2023 losing
two games in a row to the Anish Gary
another then getting that draw against
Jordan uh and then winning two games uh
in a row uh where you know if you lose
two games uh and then win two games it's
basically like you you've drawn four
games which is not great uh for for a
player like Magnus but it's not it's not
a total disaster so it's like you know
drawing four games maybe I'm gonna win a
few uh so he's definitely still in the
tournament it's hard to say whether he
will be able to fight for first place if
another back continues playing like this
uh but uh anything is possible like if
another back um draws the next three
games Magnus wins the next three games
it is possible but however winning uh
like he already now won two games in a
row winning five would be a bit over
pushing it and who's to say another back
will not win a few as well or even all
of them uh so we'll see what happens uh
Magnus does get back into the tournament
somewhat uh but uh we'll see plenty more
runs in in the event we'll see how it
goes uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh Fabi basically lost
in a few moves it was a completely new
game a move 15 and then he blundered the
game and moved 22 so really really weird
stuff happening here but yeah I hope you
guys enjoyed it and that you were able
to solve the two pause the video moments
uh I would like to thank Richard
burkot Rob classical is best and Victor
David for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
steel until it finishes so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day